- [Voiceover] In 1992,
the Japanese government
introduced strict new laws against Japan's
organized crime syndicates, the Yakuza,
in order to undermine their,
at that point in time,
substantial power.
(laughing)
Once an army of more than 80,000,
their numbers are the lowest since 1992.
And the traditional world of the Yakuza,
which has been existing
since the 17th century,
is crumbling.
- [Voiceover] To this date,
Japan has one of the lowest
crime rates in the industrial world.
With crimes related to
drugs being strikingly low.
A fact many contribute to the
very existence of the Yakuza,
Japan's so called necessary evil.
- Good morning.
Have a nice day.
Good morning!
Banzai, banzai, banzai!
Lucky!
Go, go, go, go!
(traditional Japanese music)
(gun shots)
25 years to professional wrestling.
Okay, okay!
(Japanese pop music)
- Hello, how are you?
- I am very fine.